One last note here is that we need to load in the dimple.js library in
addition to D3.
Let's go to our text editor and
look at our template file that we'll be working with.
As you can see here,
it's a pretty standard HTML file as you've seen in lesson one.
And as you can see at the top here, we first load in d3.js from D3's site.
And the second script that we're loading in is dimple.js from dimple's site.
Now it may not seem like a big deal but it's important that you put the script
to load the dimple library right below the script to load D3's library.
Since D3 should be loaded before dimple.js gets loaded.
As you can see here, in the head of our web page,
we have the familiar draw function which will get called with D3 loads in data.
And what we have here is a bunch of code to create a chart in Dimple.js.
I don't want to go through this just yet, but
I want to show you the structure of the file we're working with.
And just at the bottom here we have the familiar script tags in
the body which makes a standard call to D3 to load in
our tab separated values file world cup.tsv.
And once our data gets loaded we'll pass the data to our draw function which we
defined above.